good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1983
object class ketter presumed neutralized
special containment procedures outpost
54 has been built on the land
surrounding scp-1983
and disguised as a chemical plant the
plant
building serves as a barracks for mobile
task force chai 13
choirboys all entry points into outpost
54 are to be guarded at all times
personnel will review document 1983-12
which details the cover story to be
given to any civilians
expressing curiosity all mobile task
force must prevent
strong religious beliefs per chai 13
protocols
all ammunition stocked must have silver
or silver tipped projectiles
a 24-hour watch is to be maintained on
the front door of scp-1983-1
guards are to engage in any instances of
scp-1983-2
on-site no personnel is to approach
within five meters of scp-1983-1
outside of scheduled testing protocol
update following the event 1983-23
a stand down about post 54 has been
authorized
a skeleton crew will remain to monitor
scp-1983 for
any further activity arms intended for
use against
instances of scp-1983-2 are to be
maintained at outpost 54
armory description
scp-1983-1 is a one-story farmhouse in
county wyoming it was abandoned in 1968
after a series of ritual murders
allegedly performed by a
satanic cult police seek capture logs
for scp
for further details the front door of
scp-1983-1
when opened appears to contain a spatial
anomaly
neither matter nor light has been
observed to exit the doorway
save four instances of scp-1983-2
though the anomaly is exothermic
scp-1983-1 is accessible through other
entrances
including windows the back door and
entrances cut into the back of
scp-1983-1
however the front room does not appear
to exist inside of scp-1983-1
doors that should lead to the front room
instead lead to
other doors inside the building
measurements of the inside and outside
of scp-1983-1
are inconsistent hulls cut through the
interior walls of scp-1983-1
that should lead to the front room lead
instead to the outside walls around the
front of scp-1983-1
but stop three meters on either side of
the doorway
attempts to drill into the front room of
scp-1983-1
from the outside have led to the
exposure of smaller portions of the
anomaly
though instances of scp-1983-2 have not
been observed to exit them
further attempts to breach the wall have
been forbidden by l53
due to the possibility of allowing
increased potential
for instances of scp-1983-2 to appear
scp-1983-2 are bipedal creatures
approximately 1.8 meters tall
they are vaguely humanoid and entirely
black in color
they are highly aggressive and will
engage any human on site
when an instance of scp-1983-2 comes
into contact with a human
they extend an upper limb into the
human's chest cavity
without any apparent damage to skin or
tissues
through unknown means they then extract
the heart
killing the human once it has acquired a
human heart
the instance of scp-1983-2 will return
to scp-1983-1 silver munitions fired
while offering prayer
is the only known method of killing
scp-1983-2
the precise form of prayer or religion
of the supplicant
does not appear to matter so long as the
prayer is sincere
once killed the bodies of scp-1983-2
appear to disintegrate leaving a small
layer of sulfur
scp-1983 was discovered after a series
of mysterious deaths
in the vicinity of county foundation
investigators encountered instances of
scp-1983-2
and were able to trace them back to
scp-1983-1
addendum 1. a team from mobile task
force chai 13 was sent through the front
doorway
to attempt to investigate the anomaly
they did not return
however shortly after they entered the
front door appeared
closing in the frame no further
manifestations of scp-1983-2 appeared
addendum 2 a second assault team entered
scp-1983-1
to determine the fate of the first
assault team they did not return
the door did not close shortly after new
manifestations of scp-1983-2 appeared
agent morris entered the doorway which
closed shortly after
addendum 3. on may 23rd 1989
d-14134 was given a closed-circuit
camera
tethered to a monitor by a 25-meter cord
he was instructed to examine as much of
the area as he could
and then attempt to return once through
the doorway
feed from the camera was interrupted the
cord was pulled taut
and then snapped several hours afterward
the anomaly in scp-1983-1 disappeared
inside the desiccated remains of several
agents were discovered
as well as document 1983-15 an
informal scp report written by an agent
within the anomaly
appears as follows
item number pending
object class keta
god help you special containment
procedures
you're going to die you poor dumb [ __ ]
this isn't a threat i'm agent barkley
i'm in the middle of this goddamn thing
and i'm telling you if you're here
you're going to die i'm
probably already dead so that's out of
the way
let's get to the containment procedures
there's really only one close the
goddamn door
you aren't going to get back through
there you've probably
already tried but we know they can get
out
if they try hard enough that's how we
found this [ __ ] place
hopefully you've already done that i
know we did
once we gave up on getting out through
there if you didn't
then you go straight back and get that
door closed
that's your only priority right now
you're gonna die anyway might as well do
some good before you go
description so here's the story
tell me if you've heard it before the
foundation gets reports of
trouble in bump usa cattle and wildlife
are dying mysteriously
some people turn up missing when a body
shows up
autopsy finds the heart missing not cut
out
not torn out just gone empty space
in the middle of the chest they find
some sort of pitch-black
things floating around some brain that
the foundation has seen
something like them before figures out
how to kill them
silver bullets and pray to god as you
fire
literally for some reason that makes it
work
doesn't matter which god but you damn
well better mean it
i can't anymore not after seeing the
nest
anyway foundation figures out where it's
all coming from
some house in the middle of bump no
one's lived there in years not since
yada yada
murder cult rituals [ __ ] the main
thing is
these things keep appearing out of the
front door
a team goes in and they never come back
out but then again
neither do the monsters a same person
would say
good enough keep an eye on it kill
anything that moves
but this is the foundation you're a
tough agent from mtf whatever the [ __ ]
maybe it's aquarinos maybe choir boys
like me
you go bust down the door and run inside
and that's it
you're [ __ ] the living room is bad
enough
that's where they got o'brien they
reached in and suddenly
he kneeled over and one of them took off
with his heart in its
claws i guess they're less distinct here
you'd probably notice that they're like
shadows stay away from the light and i
know
i know it sounds stupid but think about
it in the light
shadows are stronger they have edges
but it's dark they're indistinct they
can hardly touch you
and they don't see very well i think
they see
by your shadow i don't know i'm just
pulling straws here i'll be honest
you've probably tried to go back out the
door but if you haven't
don't it leads to some place even worse
there aren't any monsters but jones went
too far from the house and i swear to
god
he started to melt things started
popping out of him and
all you need to know is he didn't make
it back
that's when we closed the door
so we started moving through the house
we kept to the light at first
before we wised up three of us gone that
way but
we got a pretty good picture of our
surroundings
this place it's big
it's not just the farmhouse it's like
they stole bits and pieces of a lot of
places and stuck them all together
there's some bits that look like an
apartment some that look like a shopping
mall
and even what i swear is a closet from
my old high school
the same patterns on the tiles and
everything there's also bits that are
made out of
stuff it's black like the shadow things
and it's mostly in the well-lit places
if the lights go out you can stick your
hand through i don't recommend it
that's how he lost taurus something
grabbed him
pulled him through the hole wasn't big
enough for his head
but he still went through eventually
so stay away from the light places but
watch your step when it's dark
of course there's no way out we figured
that out too
any door you find it either leads to
another room in this nut house or at
least out there
but it's pretty obvious we can't live
there so
it's wait until you starve to death or
one of those things gets you
great bunch of choices hey
there's one thing you can do i can go
through with it
but maybe you can
it won't help me live i don't think but
it's
i think it's important i'm pretty sure
someone's going to have to where these
things are going to get out eventually
this place is stolen from lots of places
so
i'm thinking there have to be other
doors
we've closed all the other ones we've
found but what if they get
opened again and the foundation doesn't
find them in time
hell they don't even know about closing
the doors
i'm just hoping they figure out that if
someone goes in
the things might stop getting out and
that's assuming
everyone's smart enough to close the
door after they come in
so i think i figured out a way to stop
these things
it's the nest i only saw it once
for a few minutes we followed one of
those bastards after they got denning's
heart
it took it into a room that i guess is
in the middle of this whole place
it's all black stuff and they've dragged
every kind of light they could find i
guess
lamps flashlights candles you name it
some of them were carrying in more as we
watched anyway
at the middle there's a big pile of
hearts just
tossed in a heap and torn open every one
they threw denning's heart on the pile
and it started to beat
and then pulse and then thrash around
then it tore open and one of those
things pulled itself out
it shook itself started to grow
and then went right to work
the gross thing is that torn apart as
they were
the hearts kept beating
i swear i felt a twinge in my own chest
there were shadows in the place i don't
mean
the monsters i mean real shadows of
people
only there was no one there to cast them
they were coming
from the hearts a new one appeared at
the same time as the hatching monster
and started trying to pull away but it
couldn't
that's why i ran i couldn't take it you
understand
i wasn't trained for this kind of [ __ ] i
heard the others behind me
i don't know if they were trying to stop
me or if the bastards had spotted us
but we got separated i found a nice
dark closet and i've been hiding in here
ever since
i've been writing by pen light
i turn it off whenever i hear one of
them getting close
it's worked so far
i can't go any further i've got a few
shots left in my gun
but i can't pray anymore not and mean it
not after i saw the nest but you if you
found this
you've got to be an agent too maybe
you're stronger than i was
if you can go in and destroy the nest
destroy every last heart if you do maybe
it'll kill them
it's the only thing i can think of
you'll probably die doing it but
you're dead anyway so what does it
matter to you how it happens
me i'm going to try and get this report
back to the living room which i hope
is why you found it then i'm going to
make sure they can't use my heart to
make another one of those [ __ ] things
good luck moratori
saluted
scp-1983 is presumed to have been
neutralized by d-14134
who was posthumously awarded the
foundation star
one of only two awarded to d-class
personnel
due to information contained in document
1983-15
it is believed that the anomaly was not
localized as
previously believed and renewed
resources have gone into attempting to
locate
similar incidents this concludes today's
lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
noise's conquest zargaram
professor puffer the morrigan
retalias
[Music]
revenant brian sanchez
matthew gilmore eric gorbachev
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcass death aqua king madding
james saba n.j vojak
and oblong doucheboy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen thank you
you